all right let's go to ann in tulsa
oklahoma
and what's up hey how are you
i'm super good how are you doing okay
really happy to be on the show i'm just
thrilled well i'm glad that you called
i'm thrilled as well
so we're double thrilled what's up how
can i help
so um a few weeks ago i was
hospitalized for suicidal ideation
okay i'm home now and i'm back at work
but things are still i mean kind of
weird
kind of different and i really just
wanted to know
you know how can i walk through this
season well
especially with my husband what a great
question okay so you are married you
have any kids
no no kids so tell me about what
happened what what happened and how did
you end up
in hospital yeah so i have
a history of trauma okay and
been diagnosed with ptsd and
i started having these panic attacks and
in the panic attacks
you know i would really believe that
people would be better off just without
me and so i was having
a really horrible panic attack and
believing that
and it was like something just snapped
and i was like okay well i need to find
the best way to i mean kill myself
and luckily my husband and i
were able to see my usual counselor
and you know we talked to her about
what's been going on
and you know i just i got to that point
where i was
not confident that i could promise to
keep myself
safe and so they decided that it would
be best for me to go and patient for a
while
and did kind of changed up some
medicine um
learned some new coping tools and so and
so you've been out for a few weeks
yes and how are you feeling now that
you're back home
um it's weird things are starting to get
back to normal every once in a while
like i'll do something with my husband
and
you know i'll feel that joy again
we're getting there then there's also
things that
are just really weird like what's weird
you know our medicine
well our medicine's locked now yeah and
like we're having to really pay close
attention to
like what we do and don't do to try to
avoid
like triggers and just not get too tired
so that i end up
a mess and i just feel really
embarrassed that i was there in the
first place
because like on the outside i'm still
holding it together
really well and not a lot of people know
what actually happened
okay so i want to
change this the the ending here okay
there won't be a back to normal and i
would recommend
never using that phrase again and i
would even suggest you don't want to be
back to normal because
back to normal was full of panic attacks
and trauma memories both
both in your mind and your body's
response right
and trauma the back to normal normal
sucked it wasn't good
right and so what we're doing now is we
are
building a new tomorrow that's going to
be different and stronger and more
secure
and more extraordinary than anything
the people who hurt you could have
imagined for you anything that you and
you married this
great guy could have imagined anything
that you had in your
in your heart and mind that's where
we're going now
and so sometimes the burden the weight
of trying to drag around what was
into our present is so exhausting
dude i'm just out i'm done right there's
a whole new energy with
the excitement of building something new
and the excitement of here's where we're
going
and it's going to we're going to stumble
and trip and fall and think god you've
got an awesome guy walking alongside you
but this is where we're headed and it's
going to be so rad when we get there
by the way you're never going to get
there the the big sucker punch in all
this is
that it is where you're headed right
it's awesome um
so here's a couple things you may know
this about your husband but
you scared him to death right is that
fair
yes okay is he doing the best he can
however good or misguided
but is he doing the best he can to love
you with the tools he's got
yes absolutely okay so i want you to
always
keep that in your heart and mind when it
gets super frustrating you can't just go
get some advil
or it gets super annoying that you just
want diet coke and they have locked
whatever the thing is right you and your
doctors
just breathe whoo and realize that
stupid knuckleheads trying to love me
again
right and again and again did y'all
create a
usually they'll do it together if you've
got a partner that's willing to did
y'all co-create a wellness plan together
well we did one at the hospital but it
was kind of like
a rush part of the i mean
discharge i guess okay and i haven't
gone over it
in detail with my husband and so i
probably should
yeah so here's what i would do i would
take that and i would let your counselor
know that you're doing this but you and
him can work together
on building a wellness plan that
includes both of you and he will be able
to walk with firmer footing because
you're going to give him permission to
when you see me not get out of bed two
days in a row you have permission to
call my counselor
and my counselor's got permission to
talk to you because you love me and you
don't like that i'm about to say this
and but you're only two weeks out that's
not a very long time
and so for you this feels like it's over
i would tell you you're still in it okay
and you are still um like you've seen
like a baby giraffe on the national
geographic or whatever like those wobbly
feet that's where you're at right now
and that's good it's awesome you've got
people who love you you've got
um doctors surrounded you've got
resources and that's all good
but accept that he's trying to love you
and coach him and
when he has a wellness plan that he can
live into
great and you get to speak into that too
that may mean
hey i do not at all ever want your
advice
ever ever never give me advice i hate it
i don't want it
just hug me um and man every guy i know
who's had somebody
who's tried to commit suicide in their
world just man they read everything they
can
and are just throwing facts at these
poor people and it's not helpful right
so um this this wellness plan that you
all co-create together
and i'd love it if you did it with your
counselor too all three of you would be
awesome
um but it lets you develop an honesty
and it's a strength that you're gonna
develop which is i need this from you
and you've probably
never had permission to say those words
out loud because you're a trauma
survivor
and he's gonna say i see this in you and
i
we've already talked about it i'm going
to help in this way and that way he's
not guessing and throwing things off
into the moon
and then the last thing here is you have
to promise
and swear and participate in some
ancient
bonding ritual i don't know whatever it
is like you've gotta swear promise
cross your heart hope to die stick a
noodle in your eye
that if you ever have dark thoughts
again you're gonna let them know then
you're gonna call somebody
do you promise promise promise that
yes that didn't sound very convincing
that sounded like they told you that at
the hospital and you said i will so
they would let you leave no
i mean it's tough it's hard i mean
even though i know it's the right thing
to do it's hard to see
the pain that that causes whenever you
let
i mean your husband know what's
happening
and i would say all the time well yeah
of course you do you can do hard things
and it is pain but it's a it's it's
it's pain because he loves you so much
it's pain because he's in this with you
right
he's your ride or die and so it's not
pain at him it's pain with him and
that's totally different
this is pain he signed up for right he
is in it and that's what he's for and
there will come a day when
he's going to lean on you if he hasn't
already my guess is he probably has
already what is your
what is part of your um
personal wellness journey what's your
arc with dealing with this trauma
who who are you gonna become in light of
this
i really want to become a person that
can advocate for other people that have
been through
the same stuff that i have done and just
okay but
then it's okay before you do that i want
you to advocate for anne
yeah and so easy it's easy to blow by
what just happened with you to blow by
your feelings blow by your traumas and
start focusing on helping other people
and you got to help you you've got to
believe that you're worthy of
all this wellness and love that's coming
your way part of the thing that really
annoys you
is that you don't think you're worthy of
helping and your husband does
and then he shows up and it drives you
crazy right
that's accurate and you're super annoyed
that your stupid counselor keeps
checking in on you because
who are you right the best way you can
advocate
for other people is to do the hard
gritty messy bloody yucky
hard work of getting well of
processing those traumas taking them out
of your body for good
they are a part of you they always will
be but they won't set off every alarm
you have
they won't make you so exhausted they
won't send your body off
into um just spinning out and spinning
out to where the only solution to make
this thing
is to make this thing stop right
right and it just gets exhausting is
that right
yeah absolutely often people don't
understand if they haven't sat by
somebody who's experiencing this
they don't understand it makes sense is
it ring true with you and i
the most common thing i've heard when
i've sat with people who have attempted
suicide or about to is
i'm so tired i just need this to stop
yes does that ring true
yeah okay so today it's two weeks later
how are you feeling i'm still tired
yeah um
but hopeful you know a lot of good
things came out of that and
tell me what two of them were um
i actually made friends while i was
and hey how cool is it and i'm laughing
because that's one of the most common
things i hear like i got two new bros
listen i how how
cool is it though okay
i'll back it up tell me if this is your
experience you went in there
the next morning because the first thing
they do is they make you sleep right so
the next morning you wake up
and you see a group of people and you're
like whoa
i'm not that right did you have that
experience
a cute extent some people were some
people i was like okay
i'm not the odd one out here but there
were others but yeah okay
so you're sue's you're so kind the two
responses are number one
oh my gosh i'm not alone i thought i was
nuts and i'm not alone
and number two okay they're super need
to be here
i don't right and then you start
thinking what am i doing i get
embarrassed
right so here's the thing the people who
loved you
the professionals in your life they said
this is the right place for you
and they did the right thing you did a
brave right thing um
you've got 0-0-0 reason to
feel embarrassed or ashamed okay the
same as if you broke your ankle
and you went to the doctor to get a cast
on it you wouldn't come out and people
would be like oh it's so lame you gotta
cast
you gotta actually on your broken ankle
dumb same thing
okay or if you severed a finger that you
went and got it sewed back on
no one would give you a hard time about
that this is the same situation
you had some challenges you went and saw
the right
professional care you were brave and
went to the doctor and they took care of
you and so i'm so glad you're still with
us
so glad you made this call and now it's
about
who you're gonna be you are not a
lone anne do you promise me when i tell
you that
yeah and i don't know if you've listened
to the show but one promise i make is i
won't lie to anybody
and so if i didn't believe this i
wouldn't tell you you are
absolutely worth being here tomorrow and
the next day and every day after that
the world will be a darker place without
you here okay
i know you don't fully believe when i
say that yet you're two weeks out and
that's okay
but i want you to continue to use that
as a touchstone and your husband
who has a whole lot more impact in your
life than some idiot on the radio does
he tells you the same thing okay yeah
we're glad you're here and you're worth
being here okay
now the fun adventurous exciting part of
what comes next
there is no back to normal it's all new
from here
and that's the most exciting fun part
because you get to create and build what
that's going to look like and
so glad that you got somebody you can
ride with and you met
two new folks in on the inside
and y'all can be best friends forever
you probably won't be
but hey it is super fun that you've got
those folks make sure you stay connected
to your doctor
make sure make sure you stay connected
to your counselor make sure you stay
plugged in with your husband
you all co-create a plan together so he
knows how he can best love and serve you
you know how you can slowly start taking
these steps
on standing up tall letting your voice
be heard letting what you say matters
what you want matters
and you promised in front of a lot of
people
a lot of people you promised that if you
ever have a dark moments again
if you ever think about hurt yourself
again you're going to reach out and
we're going to hold you to it
and we're going to hold you to it okay
thank you so so much for your call we
love you and we're so glad you're with
us
i cannot wait i cannot wait to see
the exciting things you have ahead of
you i can't wait to see
the grind and how hard it's going to be
in the little step after a little step
after a little step it's not going to be
easy
but i can't wait to see your journey
from here